I don't write on a computer anymore. I
actually write on this thing. It's a
typewriter. Well, it's a modern-day
typewriter from this company called
Freewrite. This is not sponsored. I just
really like the thing and I actually
write on it every single morning. The
only thing that it can do is write. It
has this like Kindle-esque display and
you can simply just write on it and
there's a button that says send and once
you're done, you hit send and it goes to
your email inbox and then from there, I
take it, I edit it and I send it as an
email or sales page or whatever I'm
writing that day, but this has helped me
tremendously from wasting time,
distracting myself on Twitter or
whatever else it is. Now, I've enjoyed
it in coffee shops. I've enjoyed it at
my coffee table and just enjoying it for
life. Again, it's not sponsored. I just
really think this thing is pretty
awesome and I think you will, too.